once you become one of those kind of
social justice warriors or something
where you get
you have to get that next one yeah
what's the next one because i'm sure
they're just bumping from
jumping from here to issue you're right
because people just jumping from the
issue to issues it's a constant need
it's a constant need so mentally what's
going on with somebody who's doing that
well i think fundamentally i mean look
there's some
truth to it right right there's things
that need to change and there's some
good things about it it's the excesses
that i'm talking about
and and the the uh well just the
excesses that's all
but somebody who goes from one to the
next they're like okay for day to day
and they're because they're
they're getting high for one thing off
it's like like a drug anything else
but it's also it's an acting out of the
most
i i this this is what i predicted so i'm
going to say it's the same thing that i
predicted
which is it's an acting out of the the
most sinful
emotion that humans have throughout
history it's always been the absolute
most i i'm sure it's been condemned by
every religion which is envy
it's like that guy's got something i
gotta bring him down to my side
wow i gotta take him down taking down
people is somehow some sort of
satisfaction
oh i got it took him down they're awful
i got him
i'm good or is at least really what's in
it is i'm bad
i just got to bring him to where i am
[Music]
so how do we how do we combat the combat
this is
like what's kind of next i start to
wonder i don't know or how do we
as so say there's somebody and a lot of
these people are like public figures
that people want to
looking to bring down that sort of thing
sure anybody that's in the crosshairs
anybody that's out in my
field of vision yeah get them now say
someone who is like
becoming a celebrity or looking into you
know wants to get into
is it wants to get into the public eye
are they how do they
not safeguard themselves but how do they
live like what kind of avenue
path do they live now i talked to
somebody yesterday about this very issue
and i just said you have to get used to
it she's got to get used to it how did
how do you how do you tolerate it go you
just gotta
you gotta go if you're not in the middle
of a [ __ ] storm regularly you don't
exist wow
if you're gonna be a public figure yeah
don't you get in [ __ ] storms once in a
while
yeah some i guess but no they don't
bother you they bother me because
because i'm so attached to my profession
right and your work yeah your everything
is very yeah you have a lot going on
because you
yeah you know your uh your education all
of that is very tied into it so i tied
into my identity when you're when you're
a physician it's like who you are you're
that you're a doctor you know right you
do what i've always done and
and when it when i get attacked all that
gets attacked with it and i just
read it yeah you're the guy that's how
you're just trying to help so you're
right especially when you're just trying
to do good it's such a it's such a
it's such a weird twist on what you're
trying to do
and by the same token i'm i'm the type
person i like to change my mind i
like it i welcome it expand change
bring it so you don't have to destroy me
you can just
instruct me right i'll happily change
i'm not going to push back unless it's
painly apparently wrong but you know
yeah i don't have to be right i don't
feel like i have to be right
no in fact yeah i don't know how to be
right because look as a scientist you
know you don't know anything
you just know you just can kind of the
best you can do is come up with a model
that predicts the future
you got that you're good yeah but truth
no
they know what's right and what's wrong
what's good for people and bad for
people
no no we it's we're much more
complicated than that particularly
picky when it comes to little giant
sweeping trends like
politics and history yeah i mean really
horrible
situations have ended up good really
good situations turned out bad
right great people have been terrible
leaders it's just i don't know
yeah yeah we'll see yeah we'll see well
i mean
i encourage everybody to have feelings
and opinions and try to do what's good
but to be so sanctimonious about it so
so self-righteous that's hubris that's
hubristic i mean sophocles
wrote tragedies about hubris and
that we want to the hubris is the belief
that i know best
period and there's no alternative and
that's that just read your sophocles
everybody it doesn't turn out well
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering
how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]